Hello I'm a citizen.
And I'm the government.
We've put a special tax on tobacco products to discourage smoking.
Oh okay. Because it's expensive to take care of smokers so your dis-incentivizing us from smoking?
Right. Also, we put a special tax on drinking alcohol because that's a problem.
Alright.
Also we're taxing your income.
Kay.
Hello I'm a citizen.
And I'm the government.
I bet you can't stop being a hypocrite for one minute.
You know I'd take that bet but gambling is illegal.
Hello I'm a citizen.
And I'm the government.
I just got paid today and you took a lot of my money.
About that—I will slowly start giving you some of that money back if and when you reach age 67.
What happens if I don't make it to age 67?